what we're going to do in this video is
talk a little bit about polynomial
identities and this is really just a
fancy way of seeing whether an
expression that involves a polynomial is
equal to another expression so for
example you're familiar with x squared
plus two x plus one we've seen
polynomials like this multiple times
this is a quadratic and you might
recognize that this would be equal to x
plus one squared that for any value of x
x squared plus two x plus one is the
same thing as adding 1 to that x and
then squaring the whole thing and we saw
this when we first got when we first
learned how to multiply binomials and
and we saw and we took the square of
binomials but now we're going to do this
with slightly more complicated
expressions things that aren't just
simple quadratics or that might not be
as obvious as this and the way that
we're going to prove whether they're
true or not is just with a little bit of
algebraic manipulation
so for example if someone walked up to
you on the street and said all right m
to the third minus one is it equal to
m minus one times one plus m plus m
squared pause this video and see what
you would tell that person whether you
could prove whether it is or is not a
true polynomial identity
okay let's do it together and the way i
would tackle this is i would expand out
i would multiply out what we have on the
right hand side so this is going to be
equal to so first i could take this m
and then multiply it times every term in
this second expression so m times 1 is m
m times m
is m squared
and then m times m squared is m to the
third power
and then i would take
this
negative 1 and then multiply and then
distribute that times every term in that
other expression so negative 1 times 1
is negative 1. negative 1 times m is
negative m and negative 1 times m
squared is negative
m squared and now let's see if we can
simplify
this we have an m and a negative m so
those are going to cancel out we have an
m squared and a negative m squared so
those cancel out and so we are going to
be left with
m
to the third power minus 1.
now clearly m to the third power minus 1
is going to be equal to m to the third
power minus 1 for any value of m these
are
these are identical expressions so this
is this is indeed a polynomial identity
let's do another example
let's say someone were to walk up to you
on the street and said quick
n plus 3 squared plus 2 n
is that equal to 8 n plus 13 is this a
polynomial identity pause this video and
see if you can figure that out
all right now we're going to work on
that together
and i would do it the exact same way i
would try to simplify with a little bit
of algebra the the maybe the easiest
thing to do first and you could do this
in multiple ways is i have this i have
these n terms two n's here eight n's
over here well what if i were to get
these two n's out of the left-hand side
so if i were to just subtract 2n from
both sides of this equation
i am going to get on the left-hand side
n plus 3 squared and on the right hand
side i am going to get 6n
8n minus 2n
plus 13.
now what's n plus 3 squared well that's
going to be
n squared plus 2 times 3 times n if what
i just did does not seem familiar to you
i encourage you to
look at the videos about squaring
binomials but this is going to be plus
6n
plus 3 squared which is 9. and is this
going to be equal to 6n plus 13
well already this is starting to look a
little bit a little bit sketchy but
let's just keep going with with the
algebra so let's see if we subtract 6n
from both sides
what do you get
well on the left hand side you're just
going to have n squared plus 9 and on
the right hand side you're going to get
13.
now are there values of n for which this
is not always true
well sure i can find a lot of values of
n for which this is not always true if n
is 0 this is not going to be true if n
is 1 this is not going to be true if n
is 2 this actually would be true but if
n is 3 this is not going to be true if n
is 4 or 5 etc so for actually most
values of n this is not going to be true
so in order for it to be a polynomial
identity it has to be true for all of
the values that are legitimate values
that you can evaluate for those for the
variable in question so this one right
over here is not
a
polynomial
polynomial
identity
and we're done